my name is Peter bad welcome to finally
being a fan
how's it going my bros I'm just gonna go
with bros cuz he's just easier even if
you're a girl well we're all we're all
roles here yeah let's just face it
welcome to Friday one feet okay for
these Fridays we put by I have a
competition to announce I'm gonna do a
giveaway and then I have some great news
and some fan art then go on it to show
wicked I guess we can start off by
showing the fan artist recently as of
late I guess this better way to say it I
don't know why but I've been getting a
lot of great great fan art but not only
fan art I've been getting like music and
people doing animations and all those
kind of stuff and I just want to thank
y'all Bros for doing that I really
appreciate it and it's really what makes
this whole YouTube thing that extra
super awesome really amazing experience
for me
and so I wanted to share with you some
of the awesome fan arts that I got her
lately really thank you guys so much for
doing this to me it really means a lot
the third thing is we're going to do a
competition for my bros basically I know
there's a lot of my girls who do Let's
Plays on YouTube and maybe you think you
aren't getting enough attention as you
deserve so we're gonna do a pretty good
being back competition where if you
check out my
Stefano's house let's play the fauna
where is it I need safar are using
Stefano no course on how lady hi all do
it
alright oh look come on the kings ha ha
are you kidding me thank the girl not me
oh you are going to basically play
through that house and doing commentary
of it and do record that and make a
video response to this video and I will
see through all the submissions and
basically the best one of my my favorite
my favorite playthrough will win and it
will be featured on next Fridays with
PewDiePie I will promote your channel as
well as I can so this is a great
opportunity and I'm gonna give you guys
a couple techniques out because honestly
if there's one thing in the world that
we are all world champions at being then
it's being ourselves so why should you
try to be me you can't beat me right you
can't beat me at being me
these creatively funny
maybe I'll choose You Pikachu next up
I'm gonna do a giveaway you giveaways
I'm getting free stuff and honestly I
hate giveaways
for obvious reasons I made a commentary
long ago how much I hated giveaways and
Here I am doing one but I'm not gonna
ask for likes and favorites for this
giveaway
all you have to do is be a subscriber
and leave a comment in the comment
section telling me why you want to win
what are you gonna win what are you
gonna win I'm gonna give out three and
three I got it right for us I'm getting
about three feet wide t-shirts and you
can choose whichever one you like just
but don't write which one you like in
all that I'll contact you with that just
right why you want to win and how much
you'll have my back mm-hmm oh yeah and
listen to the sound in the background
the guy who made who you wanna win you
I'm sorry I can't say your name mister
Chippenham 'yes he he's been working on
a Stefano dubstep and he wanted me to
show you guys a little
yes
you
it's so awesome I can't wait for it to
be released and it's just you guys do so
many things for me you do this all
awesome photos paintings you do this and
the music animations everything it's
just crazy I don't I don't know what I
did to deserve it
it really just I just love doing it and
and you know it's anything anything if
you're just involved in my videos that
really makes me happy I read all I read
almost all the comments that I'm getting
and I appreciate every single like I get
in every single favorite I really
appreciate everything you do for me
so I want to turn this video but the
epic brofist really and I know I tricked
you guys the last time but I I promise
this this is for EF in three okay I'm 1c
three
oh I'm [ __ ] getting mad all the hog
using the collar Oh bro came out of the
club